hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I'm
Jessica welcome to reasons to see where
we give you reasons to see and not to
see Iron Man 3.
so let's hang out
reason to see number one Robert Downey
Jr
RDJ he's awesome he's awesome in this
movie he makes this movie you know what
I mean he without him this movie would
have been nowhere near as entertaining
as it was yes he's got the comedy down
perfectly he's got the emotional depth
down perfectly you can feel all the
complexity all the human it's just he
gets better per movie you know I wasn't
a fan of Iron Man 2 so much but even
that I was like he's still really good
in it and he's he's just so [__]
consistent with this character after a
while it's like you know what what
emotional journey is he gonna have to
overcome
and because of such a talented actor
you're able to find that you know those
areas to explore to really go in there
and this one you know he's having
anxiety attacks because of New York what
happened in The Avengers over there
somehow he overcomes anxiety through
like post-traumatic stress and stuff
like that and and flashbacks and
insomnia and all sorts of he's kind of a
mess man this is the movie where Tony
gets to be a mess not because he thinks
he's dying but just because like his
mind is a mess after all this culture
shock so I mean yeah he does a great job
with it and I mean I feel like Robert
Downey Jr is Tony Stark because so much
of the character is synonymous with him
it's like he it's just Tony Stark's a
bigger version of Robert Downey Jr well
I like how Robert Downey Jr you know
when he plays Tony Stark there's more of
Tony Stark because he is without the
suit throughout most of the movie you
actually see more of elaboration of Tony
Stark building of his own character that
he's not just Iron Man that's why they
prefer in the movie that you know he has
the mechanic he's the one that builds
the machines but you know that's why
Jarvis takes over all of the suits and
whatnot yeah I thought that was really
cool because you see him more in action
he does a lot of all the stunts and you
know you see him Just Being Human you
see them all yeah for most of the movie
He's not in a suit he's not he's not
Iron Man for a lot of the film and uh
what immediately brought to my mind was
when watching The Avengers there's
there's a line that always really stood
out to me it's a Captain America tells
Iron Man without the suit you know then
what are you and in this movie I feel
like that's such a big theme in it you
know he is showing like even though he's
not like you know showing this to
Captain America or anything but he is
proving that without the suit he is
still a lot of you know things you see
him like still be able to kick ass
they'll be able to build from nothing
you know the guy's a total genius what's
what's so cool is he's grown the
character Tony Stark has grown a lot
since the first Iron Man he manages to
still bring that right level of
he's still like lovable you know what I
mean because he's got that charm you
know he's witty and and then you know
he's clearly sharp so there's a lot to
appreciate still it's it's so like far
from one note he knows how to bring
those layers of like yeah he's an
[__] but you can still tell he's a
caring [__] he's got a heart of
gold yeah underneath all that's uh snark
that's snarky Stark yeah yeah
this movie also sort of has that sort of
sense that Iron Man is Tony Stark not
the other way around you know I thought
that was cool so he like defines Iron
Man not letting Iron Man Define him boom
you did it yeah you nailed it and you
nailed it you're a good addition to the
show because I like how like 75 of the
time he's got the suit on it's just to
avoid dying in a really big fall yeah
it's like it's always like oh quick to
suit so that I don't smash into the
ground yeah you know honestly I could I
could actually see how that could be a
disappointment to some people how he's
not Iron Man for a lot of the film like
as I was watching it going when is he
gonna be Iron Man again because he kind
of plays more of a detective for a lot
of it you know what I mean yeah so it
did throw me off a little bit but it's
it became something that I eventually
just really appreciated when I
understood more of what they were going
for well it's got It's got a little bit
of that a little bit of that sort of
Dark Knight Rises flare where it's like
you gotta go back and relearn it you
know it's like go back and start making
gadgets again like this is where you
started in a cave with just some stuff
that was around and now you're back in a
shed with just some stuff that was
around you know working with only your
intellect reasons to see number
T action surprisingly there's not a
whole lot of action in this film out of
a two-hour movie here like three maybe
four action scenes now I think about it
there is action but there's not a lot of
Iron Man action in the film well there
are fights and then occasionally things
will explode but there are only certain
scenes where the two of those things are
happening frequently at the same time
you know but there's there is some great
action like the uh that scene they
always show in the trailer of the of you
know the helicopters attack and the
rockets attacking Tony Stark's home and
stuff I thought the trailer gave it all
away but then I watched it and I'll and
there were some few surprises in there
this movie really explores a lot more of
Tony Stark's creative side yeah like he
has a suit that's still in what what did
Jarvis call it as mk42 yeah yeah it's a
prototype and it's not fully developed
yet but he still manages to be creative
and figure out ways to take down the bad
guys with a suit that's not as effective
as his original Iron Man suit you know
what I mean it's a working Pro progress
and he's a work in progress and together
they make progress yeah I just like how
the guy that plays really I like him and
Robert Downey Jr they were they were in
their suits and they actually did a lot
more action yeah they do get to do some
some fighting side by side pepper yeah
Pepper too everyone gets to step up yeah
and kick an ass at one point or another
yeah every every movie now has a big
plane crash sequence yeah it's like the
big thing now and that was even
spectacular that was like you know a big
stunt see because it's a big set piece I
heard they use like real skydivers for
that scene that's nuts yeah that's
pretty crazy what I will say is like I
don't feel that there was like like some
people are saying this is action-packed
I don't consider it action-packed
because there are just a lot of times
where it's just scenes you know without
action but when the action's there it's
very entertaining and there's always
humor in the action too which I really
like yeah as well you know especially
that finale scene that that finale was
cool yeah I really dug that finale a lot
yeah well and even when I was having
trouble being pulled in at some other
points like especially like in act three
because like sometimes I you know I
wasn't always pulled in and act three
had some really crazy action stuff where
you know even just shots and little set
pieces and stuff that were like whoa
like those are really cool so there's
definitely a lot of really sweet action
you know I loved how um you know because
Robert down is Tony Stark builds all
those Iron Men and they come to like
save the day pretty much favorite scene
yeah it is like it is like the best
action scene that's what was really cool
they really did save the best action for
last yeah and um I love how creative it
was where he was just constantly having
to jump into suits to keep getting to
other destinations because he's a human
being and he has he's using his
intelligence and his designs to defeat
to defeat something that's rather
Supernatural in a way you know because
it's more this deals a lot with science
fiction in a lot of ways yeah and
superhuman stuff yeah exactly so it's
like how else would he defeat him
there's so many cool Parts where it's
like they're about to strike him because
they can just break through him and he
just like breaks out of the part of the
suit right there it was super unique did
not expect to see something like that
occur even there's not much action the
action's always creative always
entertaining to watch it's one of the
best reasons to watch this film it's
really the action's great reading the
state number three it's funny
it's funny
hey now I remember watching Iron Man 2
going man they lost a lot of the fun and
uh I I love the trailer for Iron Man 3
even though I eventually got sick of it
I I still love it for the most part and
what concerned me was is this gonna be
like a super serious dark heavy movie
and you watch it and it's quite the
opposite actually mainly it just strives
to be just an entertaining flick yeah
he's really witty in the movie yeah it's
it's witty humor a lot of that you know
Shane black he did a Lethal Weapon Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang and he knows how to do
like that really clever kind of banter
back and forth and you do get a lot of
that type of humor in this you know it's
kind of mean humor at times it's kind of
dark humor for the most part it's funny
I didn't find it hilarious but the
audience was certainly cracking up
enough times for me to be like yeah it's
definitely a funny film yeah yeah I mean
I I kind of found for me at least like I
felt the audience was laughing more than
I was but I was still laughing and
chuckling and stuff I mean there is a
lot of you know good humor in there I
didn't think the humor outweighed the
heavier stuff that they were trying to
do like I didn't think it was skewed
towards oh it's trying to be way too
funny I thought there was the right
amount of humor for any Iron Man movie
you know honestly at times though it the
the humor did seem a little bit like
structured to me it like sometimes it
felt like line line now put a joke there
Limelight now put a joke here a lot of
people have been saying that I I can see
it's structurally I can see what you're
getting at yeah yeah I feel like some of
the humor was like predictable yeah
that's what I mean it's like you could
see a joke even if you didn't know what
the joke was you could see like oh a
joke's probably gonna come here now a
joke's probably gonna come here now like
it yeah it definitely had that and it it
stops being as funny as it was because
there's a lot of humor pretty much
throughout you know there's rarely a
scene where it's like yeah that's just a
serious scene it's yeah they always have
funny some something funny going on
there's always something funny or
amusing but that being said it didn't
turn the movie into a comedy for me I
just thought that was sort of a trapping
of their universe is that there's kind
of a humor to everything oh really I
thought I thought one of the genres of
this particular Iron Man was comedy like
it felt like an action comedy to me
maybe I don't know for whatever reason
for me it felt like it was an action
movie that had comedy in it oh not so
much an action comedy yeah with the
amount of laughter I heard in the
audience over the amount of jokes they
have that's why I would consider it a
comedy because it's it all it is to me
is a just an entertaining film yeah but
that's a tone thing too because I still
felt like they were going for a fair
amount of heaviness with you know like
his PTSD and with like all of these sort
of more Sinister plot elements I don't
know like the tone didn't feel like
somebody made a comedy to me it sort of
it has a snappiness to it I didn't think
this was cop out you know it was like
yeah it wasn't like a sitcom where it's
like
some of the bad parts are funny like in
a sitcomic would be funny but even in
the serious scenes even when they're
talking about how he might have PTSD and
stuff when the kid brings it up they're
still making jokes you know what I mean
yeah it's humorous but I don't know I I
didn't put me in the same mindset that
watching like you know like a full-on
action comic like if I was watching 21
Jump Street I would feel very different
yeah that's sort of an action comedy too
why don't that excuse to more comedy
than action I didn't feel like this went
so far away from superhero action that
it was just a comedy well I'm not saying
it's like the top thing I'm saying like
it's superhero film action science
fiction comedy like I'm saying it is I
think it is one of the genres of the
film I'm not saying like it's just that
but I think it is one of the multiple
genres that this film is striving to be
yeah sure I mean there's always gonna
yeah there's always gonna be [__] you
reason to see number four
the visual effects come on it's Iron Man
Of course Marvel and Disney have the
money it better make it look good and
they did they did make it look good it's
not just Iron Men and robots and stuff
which all look spectacular and they've
made them even more complicated this
time around with all the little moving
parts and the fact that like the
Prototype he's working with isn't even a
full suit it's like a parts of a suit
that I'll assemble with the villains and
stuff there's this crazy like biological
fire thing they do and there's lots of
cool effects lots of different stuff
when they
um you know shot down this Mansion yeah
that was great yeah when they shot down
the mansion that was some of the best
visual effects I've seen in a movie in a
long time because it's hard to pull
something like that off and make it look
very real the cinematography behind him
just everything it complements the story
very well the visual effects it all
seems to be in the right tone the right
imagery all of it is just just spot on
throughout you know I never got pulled
out going because I was so aware it's
visual effect you know another feeling
occurs in some movies like it's so
obvious that's visual effects that
you're not as pulled in anymore yeah I
never once had that feeling with this
movie and there's some really cool like
little Easter egg nuggets just in that
third act finale you know it's like you
see all the different little Iron Man
designs and all their little working
parts and that's a cool thing to see
yeah I like that a lot too you saw the
individual like the big one that like
just crushed through everything yeah and
his and their interaction with the
effects so to speak because you really
believe there's a gag where like all the
parts of the suit keep flying at him too
fast because like the settings are a
little off and you kind of believe that
he's getting whacked by all this stuff
like it's really believable the way they
interact with all the different effects
you see how it is actually a part time
because it always falls or breaks yeah
yeah which which helps give you know I
didn't really feel there was a huge
sense of danger behind this film but it
does add a little bit more to the sense
of like man he really has to be a human
in this movie yeah because he's dealing
with a prototype out that is a little
disappointing though how you don't see
him as Iron Man yeah I I could see why
people are like uh I need to see Iron
it's called Iron Man three and it's like
he's never Iron Man in it you know what
I mean I get why someone would be
disappointed and there are a number of
times where he's operating the suit from
elsewhere yeah so you think he's Iron
Man and then they touch him and he's
like I'm in my polo shirt we saw it in
3D and honestly like the 3D is really
nothing special I barely like there were
a few moments towards the beginning
where I noticed the three in the rest of
the time I was literally going is this
still in 3D 3D so deceptive because
there's always like the opening credits
and you're like wow you're 3D words yeah
yeah then the movie starts to unfold and
you're like man it doesn't it doesn't
look like it's coming out at me yeah
well there's a Vibe I get from Marvel
especially that they kind of just do 3D
because they because you have to yeah
like I don't really think yeah it
doesn't really feel like maybe the
Avengers because I know Joss Whedon said
his style is really conducive to 3D for
the visuals but I don't really think
that Marvel is that concerned with 3D
it's like yeah whatever convert it later
you know but it's not their main concern
and it kind of shows because I mean I
kind of felt like I was watching it in
2D I was like yeah I did feel like 2D
just a lot darker yeah it's not really
enhancing The Experience there's no I
can't even think of one really crazy
money shot that was like that was a cool
3D shot because usually there's at least
one but I almost feel like the best 3D
is in movies you wouldn't expect it's
always like the one movie where it's
like yeah I I that was the only thing
that was available so I saw it in 3D and
it was great reason to see number five
Ben Kingsley Ben Kingsley he's cool in
it you know I wish they showed him more
in the movie actually a little bit
there's a lot of unexpectedly handled
things in this movie yeah and he is
certainly one of them but every time he
was on screen I I was enjoying his
presence I was like thank you for being
here because I really dig what you're
doing you know I thought they were doing
kind of like a joker thing about him
yeah like oh yeah we're teasing him a
little bit in the first half but then
we're gonna go all out Mandarin later on
yeah because it was just like little
teases of him every now and then because
you know like everyone who knows the you
know even people who don't really follow
Iron Man I'm sure they've heard most
people I've heard the Mandarin is like
Iron Man's biggest foe honestly he's
kind of barely in the [__] movie you
know when you look back on it he's not
really in it but you know what's like
different about him so usually he
usually plays villains in other movies
but he usually plays like a more serious
role and you see him in a more of a
comedic way and you're like oh and I
thought that was really funny and you
know what's interesting the way the
trailer makes this movie look it's like
it looks like Banky is it like the
Mandarin is going to be huge and Guy
Pierce is in the trailer and you're like
who the [__] is that who is he gonna be
yeah
there's some guy and
the movie then flips that where they're
like oh yeah Ben Kingsley but guy
appears is the main evil yeah which I
which in hindsight I kind of appreciate
how the trailer like messes with you but
I can also at the same time see how that
would make people very
yeah because Ben Kings is very much
advertising the trailer and you know
you'll never see me come yeah you know
most of his lines in the trailer are are
are the lines he has in the movie yeah
that's true because you know he does
have that real like comedic turn in it
where it's like it's revealed like oh
the Mandarin's just an actor yeah it's
just a a a figure ahead created Ben
Kings it does do a really good job in it
because yeah he does so yeah he sells
you on he is the leader of the
terrorists he's instantly believable
right away you know you don't really
spend too much time with him but when
he's there he is probably the most
intriguing and most scary thing in the
film yeah and it is kind of a it's funny
when he becomes just you know the
English actor that he is yeah it's funny
but at the same time I still would have
liked to see a little bit more you know
Ben Kingsley Mandarin stuff going on but
regardless of how you feel about that
turn you know it he still does a good
job playing both parts that's the thing
is like however however you feel about
what they do with the character Ben
Kingsley just his performance just what
he's given to do he does a great job
with I think I've heard a couple people
say they didn't like what happened but
they liked what Ben Kingsley did with it
yeah yeah and that's I think that's fair
at very least you know he's a lot of fun
to watch but he's just a scene number
six roadie
I like more of what they did with Don
Cheadle on this one you know like
because I I remember
um there was all that talk because you
replaced Terence Howard in part two and
I was like yeah guccio's a good actor
but I didn't really see you know like
yeah I wasn't like drastically better to
me or something but it was cool to see
it like they they really gave him a lot
more comedy to deal with I think he's a
lot more consistent with the character
and I just like the chemistry between
Robert Downey Jr and Brody yeah that's
especially that you know you don't get
too much of it in the film but when it's
there it's really fun to watch it's
really it's great to like just have it
be in there and I like that there's some
really funny stuff like when Iron
Patriot gives his uh password yeah yeah
like there's something about the comedy
in that moment where you're like that's
very comedic but it kind of makes sense
yeah exactly well because these are
these these it gives the the sense that
these are two actual guys in this
situation not just you know toys for the
plot but with Terence Howard going over
to Don Cheadle it's like you replaced
one good actor with another good actor
so not a bunch is gonna change but I
feel like this movie they did give him
finally some more fun stuff yeah instead
of just being there as his buddy and he
kicked up he did he kicked a few asses
as Roadie he kicked ass more often than
Iron Patriot yeah because what I liked
about the finale when they show up at
the harbor it's uh donch it's it's
Roadie leading the way you know and and
Robert Downey Jr is playing partner to
him because he's he's more the military
tactic kind of guy you know he's had a
colonel yeah he knows how to handle
these types of situations better than
you know Robert Downey Jr would know how
to handle it yeah and it was cool to see
them flip that and it made you know it
made having Roadie there much more
essential like that great bit where it's
like shoot out the bulb you know you
can't shoot the ball from here and it's
like well of course you know you know
Tony Stark wouldn't know how to do that
yeah but of course Roadie would you know
so it does show that yeah Roadie is an
essential part in it in part two was
kind of distracting like that's not
Terence Howard the chem I I was
questioning the chemistry to be honest
but in this one it seems you know very
natural yeah very flawless I I really
enjoyed it a lot like Don Shields was
definitely better in this reason to see
number seven seven
Guy Pierce it's funny because they
introduce him like he's a total dweeb
yeah yeah immediately his next scene
he's like the most he's super strong
he's like Mr Suave man and even though
he's barely the nerd in the beginning
he's just believable as the the dweeb
not just because of the makeup and stuff
he sells it you know I like guy Pearson
it seems like Hollywood hasn't known
quite what to do with him like yeah I
feel like he's very underrated he is and
I like seeing him pop up and stuff and I
liked that this gave him a chance to do
some kind of charactery thing and then
be an actual villain yeah before we put
him on the list I was like do we really
have to but now that I'm really looking
back on it he does do a really good job
in it yeah he brings something to it you
know the thing is though I think because
of what you might expect to hear from
the movie beforehand you're more looking
for what's the Mandarin gonna be like
what's Ben Kingsley gonna be like so
it's not that Ben Kingsley is
necessarily overshadowing Guy Pierce
it's just what you're prepared to look
for is the Mandarin yeah you're not
really looking for a guy Pierce now I'm
looking back at it and thinking about
what they were attending with the film
especially with the twist that it's
really Guy Pierce running the show it's
like yeah it's it he does a really good
job in it and he's a believable bad guy
I've never felt really felt threatened
by him and I don't really blame it on
him I blame him more on the tone and the
directing of the movie yeah but what
what he had to do he certainly brought
his a game for it yeah and when he
finally like towards the end when he
finally gets to unleash and not only be
the The Mastermind but also the monster
that's when I I did feel a bit I did get
that threat finally this movie is so
weird if you think about the trailer
because the trailer is a trailer for a
different movie with the same characters
so so that's true I can see why you
would be let down initially but take a
look at what Guy Pierce is doing because
he he does do a good job yeah I feel he
delivers a good performance in a lot of
ways he is like the perfect match for
Iron Man yeah he is I mean because
they're you know like in part one it was
the guy who always wanted to be in Tony
Stark's position so at the end of day
was always under Tony and then in part
two it's you know Whiplash you know
Mickey Rourke it's just my birth yeah
and then it's uh Sam Rockwell you know
with a competing yeah but it's it's com
clearly like Tony Stark's business is
way better yeah but then you know guy
Pierce's character steps in it and he's
like look at this [__] you can see my
brain you know what I mean yeah you can
check out my brain we can rebuild human
like you know Limbs and stuff we can fix
lives in a whole different way because
in a lot of ways you know it's like a
lot of the theme is uh you know Tony
Stark is Iron Man and this guy he
whatever that creation is extremists
extremists yeah he is extremist yeah
essentially you know what I mean and to
have the two go up against each other
like that it was it was the Perfect
combo pair because their mentality is a
lot on the same level it's like Yin and
Yang in a lot of ways yeah yeah exactly
and you also see in the movie like they
actually have history yes yeah and
that's that's cool like he always hit on
pepper and you know he turned him down
20 times put him down like yeah they
actually have history he actually has a
grudge towards again against
um 20 Stars yeah his motives make sense
yeah well and they're grudged between
them like the ultimate reason kind of
why all this happened is because of Tony
being Tony yeah because he's a dick to
him and he goes off to get laid and then
if that hadn't happened all this could
have been very different so it's like
you know because you were doing what you
do with me being with the other head
yeah I came back to haunt you now and
then you know that's cool stuff to think
about reason to see number eight
pepper pots you know it's cool they give
her a lot more things to do in this
movie you know they yeah but not as much
screen time it's yeah that's weird
that's true that's true they gave her
they didn't give her a lot of screen
time they don't really focus so much
like the the relationship is very
important to Tony yet it doesn't really
feel like there's much of a romantic
story in that movie in this one yeah so
they're already together and stuff you
know like no one really cares to explore
the relationship well it is because of
all the problems that Tony's having
right now is making their romantic
relationships suffer so it's more about
fixing that stuff then but they gave her
new stuff to do they put her in
situations that you don't imagine
Gwyneth Paltrow's character being in it
yeah she she delivers on it like she
does she sells it yeah well and as her
status changes and her relationship to
Tony changes the things that happen to
her then change so in this movie she is
the bargaining yeah and Pepper's
actually put in a really serious
predicament yeah yeah very serious and
you're like oh wow you're not just
behind the screen worrying about yeah
exactly you are being worried about it
yeah
it does play with that damsel and
distress type of theme but it also puts
a Twist on it at the same time you know
so I do respect you know not that I like
this movie more than I thought
yes that's why I want to watch this
again because it's like I I've spent the
movie going why am I not more into this
and now I'm talking about it I'm like
there's so much good yeah yeah there's a
lot of great elements at play here yeah
it's weird because they have good
surprises with pepper you know like I
love that moment when that it's like I'm
so glad they didn't show it on the
trailer that moment where um the house
is blowing up because I remember
watching the trailer they're flying in
slow motion with burned oh yeah and I
was like how did she survive that [__]
you know and then the suit latches on
her and he gets I got so much emotion in
that scene because I was like dang Tony
that's smart yeah yeah you really
thought about this scene yeah you
obviously like thought about what if
someone attacked I don't know what you
notice that pepper finally actually
protected Tony Stark that's what's cool
is the rolls do switch Yeah she protects
she protects them twice yeah she saves
his ass when he's in the Iron Man suit
that's easy I really like what they do
with the scene you know how just like
latch onto everybody as soon as a
strange entity in this movie because it
really serves a different function yeah
it's almost it's it's it's larger than
just Tony Stark anymore yeah so that
moment where like they try to make you
believe that pepper died I didn't buy it
I I didn't I did for a second for a
second there I was like oh no because
like you know he didn't catch her on
that stuff and then immediately as I
went oh no I was like oh no wait we
there's shots we haven't seen in the
trailer and stuff like that nip and and
that extremists will probably work and
she'll probably kick ass but for a
second there I believed it was it was
pretty it was predictable but it was
still pretty cool when it happened this
movie goes back and forth between doing
a lot of things that you wouldn't expect
and delivering on things that you kind
of want from it and that was one of
those predictable moments where I was
actually rather satisfied when it when
it occurred we get a lot of those like
female characters who are just always
put in the Damsel in Distress situation
yeah and it's like that's all they are
you know they catch each other you know
yeah yeah it's great it has a great
moment yeah you actually you kind of
actually see the relationship like it's
a partnership yeah yeah it's a real
partnership and she's capable of kicking
ass you know were you just the scene
number nine the kid
yeah man there's a whole portion of this
movie where it's Tony and a kid yeah and
they're hanging out and they're getting
into trouble yeah they explore and
especially in part two they explore Tony
dealing with his father issues but in
this one you kind of get Tony being a
little bit of a father figure in some
ways you know it's kind of an abusive
yeah but you would expect him to be kind
of he's like he's kind of like you know
like the the tough dad figure in a way
yeah but kind of he's like the
combination of your dad and your big
brother yeah yeah yeah definitely you
know because Tony calls him a friend at
one point and they're like you know what
it is more of a friendship type of thing
but it's like the kind of friend that
you do admire you do aspire to be like
you know what I mean it was great that
was that was some of the best scenes in
it yeah well because it's it's really
endearing and it doesn't lose the edge
and it's not like you know cornball or
annoying really because it's it's easy
to get into that territory when you're
like oh it's superhero and a kid now you
know what too that the kid was in a
similar place as Tony Stark as a little
boy you know he didn't have his father
yeah and you could see that he was he's
a genius because he's helping build the
suits and you could see that he's like
oh oh you're the mechanic yeah yeah oh
it's so cool and you see him taking the
parts here and he knew he knew what he
was doing they do have like a like a
kinship yeah from that and then when he
helps out with Tony and saving his life
and stuff like that it's actually
believable yeah the movies that try that
[__] it's always like corny the kid's
annoying it's like it's like [__]
that Asian kid from Indiana Jones too
yeah yeah and he has the same like humor
or not the same here but the same witty
sense as Tony Stark and he's like oh man
knowing you should I stop yeah like JPS
the kid the kid's good you know like
that's what I mean it's like not just
the way he was written not just the way
the director captured it it's like you
the kid like
Ty Simpkins yeah yeah
Ty Simpkins he he doesn't he does a good
job in it that it's hard to get a child
actor who will not be annoying and well
yeah and that and that's credit to him
and the writing too because it's like
he's not written as one of those
annoying movie kids who's like I can
hang with the adults and I'm using all
kinds of precautions I'm loud and
annoying yeah it's like you just believe
he's a kid whose mom is working all the
time and his dad's not around like you
believe that yeah and he's got that
Essence and I've seen a Ty Simpkins in
some other stuff lately I think he was
in like Dark Skies or something and like
and he's he's a good actor like he can
that little dude can do it you know he
he plays he plays off of uh Robert
Downey Jr so well and they gave a good
conclusion to the kid too and like yeah
when he gets all this stuff I like that
that made me feel good yeah that was a
good heartfelt moment you know reason
not to see number one
doesn't take advantage of Iron Patriot
so we said Roadies we're being technical
about it yeah Brody is a reason to see
there's a lot of hair splitting on those
reasons Iron Patriot's not a reason to
see though it kind of sucks that they
advertise Iron Patriot there's all this
talk that Iron Patriot's in the movie
yeah and that was like the one like Set
photo that they were leaking forever
yeah and it's like you you think oh yes
they're gonna really take advantage this
time they hyped it up one this is the
one time where that deceptive marketing
thing actually kind of was sort of
truthful because they were like no no no
we're not doing Iron Patriot guys calm
down it's just a paint job and then it
is Iron Patriot done done but it's still
kind of not because he's not in it yeah
because he doesn't get to do much and
they don't give him much to do it was a
letdown and it keeps sliding Roadie on
the suit situations because it's like we
see Roadie in the suit but he's just on
the phone yeah and then he shows up at a
different point in the suit and then he
gets out of the suit and then he doesn't
do anything cool with the suit like he
shows up Kicks the door open it's a
bunch of like you know
Taliban women
I remember in part one they they uh
teased that so perfectly yeah you know
like the next time yeah yeah I remember
watching everyone it was like oh my God
and then in part two when he puts on
this the suit and sort of becomes War
Machine in that moment at the party it
was like that's how they're introducing
and becoming war machine is Tony's drunk
at a party and he has to and Roadie has
to break up the party before it gets too
out of here I think if they put him in
the second Avengers I think jaw Sweden
will really know how to take advantage
of him yeah well because they've left
him room to work with it's because like
Tim all the room yeah recent enough to
see number two
uneffective drama and intensity it took
me a while to get really pulled in where
it was like that was just it because for
me this movie is yes it's entertaining
without a doubt like you're even if
you're just not pulled in but you're
just observing it it's an entertaining
flick that's all it really was was just
an entertaining
and it doesn't really have an impact you
know like I know we should just take it
as a standalone film and if its job was
just to entertain they certainly
succeeded well they always do that's
what mainly Marvel movies is about I
know this isn't a movie that's
necessarily about the emotional depth
but there's a lot of stuff in here where
it's like I should feel more yeah it
based off that yeah it's weird because
it's like this movie has everything it's
there it's all it's on the screen yeah
and I spent more time though like the
one the one jarring thing to me about
this movie is that I spent more time
trying to figure out why am I not more
pulled into this yeah exactly because I
only really got fully enthralled like
fully pulled in close to the end like
somewhere part way through act three
when you know things were finally
starting to get crazy there were moments
that I was really engaged in but the
movie itself didn't sustain me until
close to the end yeah it's like I feel
like I walked in 10 minutes late it felt
like that to me too I felt like I walked
in a little late when you when pepper
fell and I didn't feel Tony Stark was
still like yeah he was affected but I
didn't feel like I mean if my love of my
life died I've been like oh my God like
I'm so distraught like he wasn't just it
just feel like it wasn't distracted you
know what I mean like it almost feel
like like the movie itself doesn't give
the the character's time to feel stuff
yeah yeah exactly there's always
something else they gotta go to right
now it moves at an entertaining Fast
Pace but you know what made part one
great and a lot of these Marvel movies
really good even the Avengers is there's
a level of emotional depth in there
there always is there's an emotional
core and you can feel that because
you're still exploring characters yeah
yeah so when you that's what makes it
even more I felt like the humor started
to lose its effect because that's all it
really was being was just entertaining
you know yeah and when it does it
doesn't have that emotional core that's
felt it's it's so it was strange because
it's like it's all there in front of me
yet a lot of it's not being felt I don't
really feel a sense of danger I don't
really feel a sense of
motivation I felt like it's they always
went back to like oh here's something
that's going to be effective but let's
just go back to fun like okay the
Mandarin for example I didn't feel that
like they really build them up in the
trailer especially in all the press and
all the talk but I didn't feel this urge
like yes he has to be taken down you
know what I mean like yeah it's like you
just start getting to know the extent of
this sort of really scary image he's got
and right when you're starting to start
to feel that then they give the big
reveal and there's another manner in in
that context I feel like they gave away
the villain too early dude like you're
so right about what you said about the
Mandarin too about like you're just
starting to feel him just starting to
get there and then it's like they then
they pull the twist yeah yeah it's like
that twists could have been more I'm
overweighted make him make me hate him
and then pull the two yeah exactly it's
like yeah what I mean like it's for like
oh you we saw him him being the actor
first rather than yeah the other guy
would feel like he's actually a
character you know it's like oh well
that's something like there's a lot of
like moments there's like twists and
turns but none of it it's like it's like
oh it felt like it was too quick yeah it
reads his past well I I do gotta agree
with you on that like there was a split
second in the movie where she's like my
boss you know uh Aldridge Killian is
working with the Mandarin then they come
to him and he's like I am working with
the Mandarin yeah not exactly like that
but I was like oh you're just gonna out
with it like yeah there's gonna tell us
like it's just like I mean we didn't
know whose exactly but we have gonna be
like oh but you're working with him and
obviously he's he has to do it because
he it shows in the flashback that he got
screwed over by Tony Starkey he's like
oh it sounds like the script is outlined
well they knew like oh yes you should
have this scene here but like for
example in the finale yes pepper dies it
looks like she dies but then it's like
uh okay I guess we're past that moment
you know what I mean yeah it just moved
faster right away there's no like I mean
because like something happens right
after that moment where he has to handle
his himself but I feel like there ought
to have been a come down moment where
it's like the chaos is stopped oh God
now it's hitting me and then bring
pepper back and then but even when they
win they defeat Guy Pierce they're still
like
all right good job high five do you know
what I mean it's still yeah we did a
good job let's let's move all the Iron
Man now I know we save the world another
time even though we're at the bay and
it's probably gonna be hard to find some
Transportation let's just blow up all
the Iron Man right now and then even
that moment where he's like I got a
message for the Mandarin yeah it's like
they're playing this patriotic music
they're like whoa whoa whoa I don't I
don't feel it yet you're already giving
him your home address like oh slow down
man it would have Amplified everything
yes entertaining fun but seriously like
it I do miss that I really felt like I I
wasn't as pulled in because of that
Split Decision number one Mandarin
Ben Kingsley does a good job with the
role they wrote Of The Mandarin yes yeah
does a good job I got a big problem with
how they portrayed the Mandarin though
because it was such a letdown for how
the Mandarin is is built up villain it's
established Iron Man's greatest Foe and
yes it's a funny twist what happens but
at the same time it can to me it was
kind of a letdown because it's like well
what about all the hype of this being
Iron Man's greatest [__] I can totally
see how a Die Hard fan of the comic
books will be very pissed off or how
even just like a regular viewer if you
haven't read all the comics you've seen
the trailer you're like oh [__] Ben
Kingsley like yeah looking like this
crazy villain you know that looks
intense that being said I get I I cannot
you know argue that anyone shouldn't be
upset by this yeah like that's just such
a wild moment and I appreciated how off
the wall that was because I wasn't
expecting it and like I said for my own
purposes I thought that was a really
cool touch and the only thing that could
have made that better is if like we
really learned to hate the Mandarin and
then this
but just what you said like learn to
hate the Mandarin you don't learn to
hate the Mandarin like ever and it's
like if they they set him up as the
villain honestly Guy Pierce does a good
job Peter but the bits you get of Ben
Kingsley as a villain I found more
interesting than Guy Pierce those little
hints and bits that they were like so
building up throughout this movie was
very intriguing like whenever bankings
it was on screen as the Mandarin was
awesome he he executed it perfectly and
it looked like we were gonna get a great
Thrill Ride coming with him later but
that twist is like oh we just we can't
all that you know what I mean it's like
all the things they they hyped up about
it what people would have expected it
was there but then they threw in
something else threw in a Twist yes
funny I still was cracking up at it but
in overall on the grand scope of things
I was let down big time by yeah they
turned him into Comic Relief they do but
at the same time I thought it was clever
to the story because the whole reason
that they do it I thought was actually
pretty cool it's like he's created this
figure ahead to like intimidate all the
world while also covering up his
screw-ups while also trying to enact
something like Global you know it's like
I thought it was a clever plan it's like
I get why it's an upsetting letdown of a
plot point but I thought that I found it
very amusing but I also thought it was a
clever part of guy pearce's time because
basically Guy Pierce is the Mandarin
test it's clever but I don't feel they
should have done that with the Mandarin
it's just because it's the Mandarin it's
like what if they did that because I
know they want to do this with Batman
but it's like imagine that they did that
kind of with the joker yeah like that's
that's what I mean because that is
essentially who the Mandarin is to Iron
Man and to do that it it's kind of I
kind of find it a little bit insulting
to to the fans of the comic and I didn't
even read the comic you see if this
didn't have the history if if this was
just a stand-alone entry into a movie
franchise called Iron Man then I
probably would be perfectly fine with it
but because of what of how it was
advertised the hype behind it the
anticipate like the Mandarin was
supposed to be the the first villain in
in in the first Iron Man but they were
like no that might be too much for the
first time too much to have and so I I
guarantee you they did not plan on doing
what they did you know and so there's
people have been waiting for the
Mandarin to be in it yeah and it's like
that's not what happens in the comics
and I did my research to make that
[__] statement and that's not what
happens in the comics and it's such a
big thing to do yeah you know it's like
not fully explore the biggest villain in
Iron Man's life is it's like doing that
to the Joker in Batman like you would
never want to touch that yeah you want
to explore it rather than sort of turn
it into something else at the same time
I see I see where you're coming from
that's why I said all those things I I
do get where you're coming from you know
I'm a big fan of the idea that like yeah
you know yes it's the movie
representation but it's also it's its
own thing and somebody's got their own
artistic spinner from my perspective I
Gotta Give Marvel a bit of of respect
for that because like that that took
some balls to go with that because like
thank God they had to know people would
get upset on the one hand yeah it is it
is a slight defense you know some people
are going to be mad it's probably the
thing that Disney would do that's what
that sounds like a
Disney have I don't think it's Disney
though I really don't because I don't
know typical Disney thing would do too I
could see why you respect it but at the
same time I respect it on principles
yeah I understand why people yeah and
there's a flip side where it's like
that's not a very that's something you
might consider that disrespectful you
know what I mean and it's very
borderline brace because I mean like I'm
like this worked for me I'm surprised
you thought it would work for most
people though like so I can't fall again
I can't fault anybody for not liking it
because I totally get even if you had
known nothing about the books just
having seen the trailer I totally get
why you would be mad well and I'm pretty
sure if you're different it's different
if you read the comics and it's like
yeah
they're so hyped up like oh my God this
is the greatest villain in Iron Man
comic books and you know when they see
it they're like oh like you just
completely butchered what yeah the
reality of the situation is this there
is the history of the manor there is
that Legacy there is the hype all that
does exist so we can play the game of
what if that didn't exist but the
reality is it does exist so that I'm
thinking like how are most people going
to react truthfully that's just how I
reacted yeah no and this is the the
conundrum of comic book movies in
general is that everyone kind of views
them it's the same with remakes too it's
like everyone kind of views them from a
slightly different perspective as to
what they're expecting the adherence to
the source material should be my
temperament is generally like yeah it's
somebody else's version I take it as
like another Iron Man story written by
somebody yeah with an idea just like
there are a bunch of different Iron Man
or Batman books with different takes
that's why the Nolan Trilogy the Nolan
Dark Knight trilogy is cool because he
does create his own comic in a way and
it's it's clearly his take and it's less
clearly so with Marvel because it's just
marvel but you know it is that comic
book conundrum of what are you allowed
to take liberties with and what are you
supposed to stick true to and what is
how much flexibility do you have
creatively when going from already very
established material to the movie
versions but even excluding the twists
you still don't get enough Mandarin and
even though I like the twist The Twist
would have been that much better if the
Mandarin was that much more evil yeah it
would have been a reveal you know like
rather than a comedic twist that occurs
yeah because it even it wasn't even that
big of a reveal the way how they
portrayed it but then I also have a hard
time believing who's this stupid yeah
that kind of yeah that kind of suspends
my belief a little bit because like who
is this dumb yeah I mean that's I don't
know it's just a junkie yeah I guess but
he's a very talented junkie
really portraying evil
selling the whole world
you're a really good actor for a junkie
man that's why I think this film is a
comedy Split Decision number two
the ending
okay well you mean the post credit sting
well kind of both of after the finale
and post-credits thing okay because
after the finale it's like all right
let's just wrap it up you know what I
mean throw a montage in there and just
wrap everything up they're kind of
trying to make you believe in a way that
this might be the last Iron Man and I'm
like this just seems like a sequel flick
and I feel like we could evidently have
more well I felt like they left it open
enough that they could if they wanted to
or if the stars align but they also left
it it's kind of like you know it's like
they're moving on I don't think it's a
solid conclusion though to this story or
not not even just the whole story I mean
just even part three in general it's
like they rushed the conclusion it's
rushed but I feel like the the finality
is there if they want it to me it goes
back to how this has uneffective drama
and intensity because it's like yeah
that okay they they wrapped it up Tony
got the the crap out of his chest and
okay pepper gets the thing inside the
extremists inside of her and then
through Tony just now reading it yeah I
fixed it yeah it took a while but I
fixed it you know and the whole three
movies plus the Avengers he has this
thing in his his heart and it's like
yeah and I got a scrapple out of it like
everything you just yep yep yep
concluded and I'm not an Iron Man
anymore life is good I get you know like
I'm not arguing it's not that it's not
rushed at all because it is a little bit
like and then we fixed everything the
end it's like that yeah but it does feel
like they put a bow on it and if they
want to take it off again they can
without too much effort but that's what
I mean it's like like they the
conclusion isn't felt though you know
like with the dark knight rising I know
these are completely separate I know
this is DC Comics but we're sorry but
with Dark Knight Rises like yes that
feels like a conclusion with the Dark
Knight in terms of just that movie alone
that had a conclusion to that story and
this one you know what I mean like it
didn't bug me so to speak it's another
one of things where it's there the
stuff's there it it might not be as
impactful because it is rushed but it is
that's the word it's there but it's
unpackful yeah it was like that's it
yeah that's what I meant that's what I'm
waiting for like that's it and then in
the post-credits scene I liked it it was
funny but at the same time I would have
wanted a little bit more of a tease yeah
I've learned how if I knew that was
going to be the end the postcard I
wouldn't have waited like with the
Avengers that was okay the Avengers they
have the tease at the end during the
middle of the credits and then they have
the funny conclusion uh where they're
all eating Shawarma like that was great
but in this one it's like everyone was
sticking around because they wanted to
see us all right what's the next tease
yeah
people were wanting that and I feel like
they should have given that yeah I
wouldn't have stayed if I knew it was
gonna be funny scene yes good scene
executed well but I felt like it yeah
but think about it I mean like it's like
the first Iron Man it's the first of
these big Marvel is a stu its own studio
now it's like oh Marvel and then we see
Iron Man In The End Nick Fury comes in
he's like I'm putting together a special
team and everyone's like oh my God
they're not they're doing the Avengers
it's like what do we have to announce
now like we know what the second uh
Avengers movie is roughly gonna be about
or at least who the main villain could
be it's like what are we building
towards now besides another Avengers
movie and also it's the first step of
phase two and if you look back on phase
one it didn't seem like they had their
thing really like concretely figured out
until like Thor and cat came out because
like Iron Man the first one was so far
in advance it's like all they knew is
yeah we're doing the Avengers but I feel
like the plan hadn't had like a
structure yet and phase two is just
beginning so I wasn't really expecting
them to be like surprise unless they're
gonna do something crazy but yeah but
they did a teaser in The Avengers didn't
they yeah they did so we know what the
Avengers 2 is going to be about yeah but
even but even with like the ending of
like Thor and stuff like I know you've
seen those came later but they still
teased like what it will be about and
what we might explore like they they
show at the end of Thor that uh Loki is
still around and he's gonna be and he
has the the ability to probably grab the
I forgot all the [__] names of
everything yeah
there we go yeah you know that's funny
they give really solid teases there and
I felt like they could teach something
that we could have looked forward to him
yeah because if they were just able to
do an Adventures like they had an idea
you know they could have just elaborated
it was just you know but you are right
fresh though you are right in the sense
though that maybe they don't know fully
what it is I know like Joss Whedon just
wrapped up an outline so maybe they
you're right yeah so maybe they don't
know because they filmed Iron Man three
months ago so I feel like they could
have been created enough to come with
something yeah also I'm the other thing
too is as long as we're talking about
this could be the last Iron Man I feel
like it would be weird of them to be
like Tony Stark doing some Iron Man
thing later on down the line but we
don't know if he'll be here
Tony Stark will return but it's still a
question mark as to what what Robert
Downey Jr's involvement is so we don't
know if Tony Stark will only return in
The Avengers or if there'll be an Iron
Man then I gotta go back to the
Incredible Hulk because Norton wasn't in
The Avengers yeah but they still teased
The Avengers in at the end of The
Incredible Hulk they teased it during
the Incredible Hulk he comes to him in a
bar scene that's the very last scene
yeah but but still it's it's like that I
know it's not post credits but it's
still it's still it has it has nothing
to do with the rest of the movie it all
has to do with the Avengers I I'm sure
they I'm almost positive they would have
done that during the production of that
movie and they probably didn't know at
that time that they weren't going to
keep Ed Norton around plus we've already
had up on no different holes but no no
they didn't know if they're going to
keep Ed Norden around or not what matter
they said Tony Stark will return so they
still could have teased it with Tony
Stark and then they if they want to
replace him they could have replaced him
because with Edward Norton you're sure
he's not in that scene but it was still
Edward Norton as the one yeah but the
thing is that they'd already it was only
Edward Norton's first Hulk movie we'd
had Eric Bana before that this is like
don't promise you're gonna have Robert
Downey Jr if you're not gonna have
Robert Downey Jr because we just got
done talking about how he is Tony Stark
so I feel like it would be it would be
weird to be like hey Tony doing
something avengersy and then if
something doesn't work out he's not
there and then that's going to be let
down well they didn't have to do
something with Tony sorry at the end of
Iron Man too it's Thor's hammer at the
end of uh at the end of Thor you don't
even see Thor you're like that's what I
mean like you don't see them he doesn't
have those things Iron Man those things
still tied into those movies though
because it's like Coulson is a big
character in Iron Man too that's what I
mean like they it still should have tied
into one of the movies I feel like yeah
but but the but the stings on those
movies still tied into the movie we had
just finished watching it's like Coulson
was a big character in Iron Man too so
it makes sense that we could cut to him
instead of being like hey at the end of
Iron Man a character that has not
appeared in this movie at all is about
to do something like they could have
still done that and it would have still
been Rad but I I get why they wouldn't I
thought this was cool because it's like
the post-credits thing made her to wrap
around I just thought it was very cool
that the whole movie is basically him
recounting a story to Bruce Banner which
I thought was really funny I felt like
that could have been the ending scene
not the post-credits scene though yeah
that yeah I wouldn't have stayed and
waited for that like when I saw them I
could really like I waited for this like
well you waited like three minutes see
if I'm getting from hers like you gotta
think most people leave after class I
know like we'll stick around because I
would
usually stick around but because it's
Marvel a lot of people tend to stick
around yeah because we know oh Iron Man
he's a part of the adventures and you
know he's gonna be involved with
something else and or even like Thor
like you know you you stick around for
that like you know because yeah it's
Marvel you you know they're probably
gonna put something after the question
yeah no I get you I mean also too I
thought it was a fun it could be a fun
fan thing because they took everyone's
two favorite Avengers anytime Tony Stark
is around people are gonna be like he's
my favorite but the other one I heard is
everyone was like oh yeah Mark Ruffalo
is a great Hulk it's the best one we've
had so far so I can still see that being
exciting it's like oh nice it's our two
favorite of editors yeah I know like it
it no it's I'm saying it's a good scene
but it doesn't leave you with an
anticipation for something else yeah
Ryan's consensus there are entertaining
reasons to see Iron Man 3. there are
entertaining reasons to see Iron Man 3.
a lot of the you know awesome intensity
and dramaticness of a lot of the the
Marvel films I love especially the first
Iron Man but overall it's here to
entertain it's starting off the summer
and it delivers on entertainment Jerry's
consensus there are a lot of reasons to
see Iron Man 3 but not quite as
there are a lot of reasons to see Iron
Man 3 but not quite as many as you would
think yeah I mean it's it's got all this
stuff it's all there and it's a fun time
it's good for some reason wasn't fully
sucked into it you know
um but I like it go see it for sure you
might I hope you dig it Jessica's
consensus cinematic fun is the reason to
see Iron Man 3. cinematic fun is the
reason to see Iron Man 3. you know it's
good action film but if you're a comic
book fan obviously you're gonna be
pissed but yeah you're gonna be pissed
but other than that
it's good if you're not a comic book fan
I guess because people don't know
all right guys thanks for checking out
our show why don't you go ahead and go
to that comment box below and tell us
which one is your favorite Iron Man now
that the all three have come out now and
uh if you want to check out more
episodes of reasons to see click the
link right yeah and if you want to check
out my straight to the point review of
Iron Man 3. almost forgot the title of
the movie click the link right here and
if you want to get updated every time a
new review or a video is out
subscribe click on Jessica yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah click that Asian button
right there yeah
you know what I really appreciate is
that they spelled Iron Man 3 t-h-r-e-e
at the end do you think this is a little
thing it zooms towards the screen and I
was like that's kind of cool yeah
there's a little bit of fun vibe in the
ending credits I like those ending
credits yeah yeah subscribe subscribe
subscribe to Jessica she'll call you
yeah we're opening up a hotline so I do
viral marketing yeah I I she's my cousin
and I want her to meet more people so
subscribe and she will talk to you
you're like a half endearing half really
creepy pimp well yeah it's more for
money reasons some more creepy more more
pimp yeah more more creepy than
endearing yeah yeah yeah nice to know
yeah thanks
oh